[Music]
history is nothing but the progress of
the consciousness of Freedom meditate on
that thought for a bit let that thought
marinate in your mind for a bit history
is nothing but the progress of the
consciousness of Freedom there is
nothing in the world more precious to
human beings than Freedom since the dawn
of Consciousness and the realization of
the fact that we are aware of our own
existence freedom is positioned at the
epicenter of our experience throughout
time the notion of Freedom has evolved
in tandem with a state of The Human
Condition hence history is nothing but
the progress of the consciousness of
freedom and there was one person who
realized that more than others and made
it their nucleus of his thinking that
person was Georg Wilhelm Friedrich Hegel
he is considered one of the founding
figures of modern Western philosophy and
many say that no philosopher of the 19th
or 20th centuries has had as great an
impact on the world as Hegel he has been
quite an enigmatic figure for me since I
first heard his name must say that his
writing style is obscure and even
repulsive at times regardless I thought
it was about time to demystify this
legendary figure and understand why his
work is considered so impactful and
unique
Hegel was born on 27 August 1717
Stuttgart capital of the duchy of
videnberg in Germany his father was
secretary to the revenue office of the
Duke of Wittenberg his mother was the
daughter of a lawyer he had a brother
and a sister during his childhood he
developed a huge appetite for reading
especially for writers associated with
the enlightenment at the age of 18 he
entered the Protestant School of the
time where he had as roommates the
future philosophers hilderlin and
shelling he admired greatly the Greek
civilization and became obsessed with
the French Revolution in 1801 Hegel
moved to the city of yena in Germany
after the encouragement of his friend
shelling who was already a professor at
the University of the city there he
started writing his most famous book The
phenomenology of spirit it was a very
dense philosophical work that attempted
to build a science of Consciousness so
to speak Hegel wanted to explain the
evolution of consciousness
from childhood and basic awareness to
self-awareness and absolute knowledge it
was published in 1807 a very interesting
incident in hegel's life occurred in
1806 when Napoleon marched in the city
of Vienna one day before the battle
between the French and the Prussian
troops outside the city Hegel wrote in a
letter about his encounter with the
emperor I saw the emperor this world
Soul riding out of the city on
reconnaissance it is indeed a wonderful
sensation to see such an individual who
concentrated here at a single point
astride the horse and it is out of the
world and Masters it this extraordinary
man whom it is impossible not to admire
in 1811 Hegel married Helena Susanna
fonteher this period saw the publication
of his second major work the science of
logic and the birth of two sons Carl
Friedrich Wilhelm and Emmanuel Thomas
Christian in 1818 Hegel accepted an
offer of the chair of philosophy at the
University of Berlin where he stayed
until his death in 1831. his last words
are said to have been there was only one
man who ever understood me and even he
didn't understand me
what is history really could you define
history in one sentence the great
historian Timothy Snyder in one of his
recent lectures on the war in Ukraine
said the following
um so history is about change of
continuity which means it's about ends
and beginnings and it also it's also
about unpredictability
through history is changed and
continuity I would go one step further
and say that history's change continuity
and evolution throughout history there
was one philosopher who quite adamantly
supported this idea William Hegel and
this is depicted in a series of lectures
he gave at the University of Berlin in
1922 1828 and 1830 titled lectures on
the philosophy of History upon reading
some of the text and mainly analysis of
the text I realized that I was a
hegelian since a long time without even
knowing Hegel in the philosophy of
History sets out to explain something
groundbreaking and visceral for the
human psyche he tries to present history
as a very sophisticated process that
moves towards a very specific goal the
realization and cultivation of human
Freedom as he says the question at issue
is therefore the ultimate end of mankind
the end with the spirit sets itself in
the world what does that even mean what
does it mean for the spirit to set
itself in the world the translation is
not the best but it roughly means for
the human Spirit to realize its
existence and self-actualize Hegel uses
the word Geist in German which most
people translate as spirit with the word
Geist he doesn't allude to something
metaphysical but rather to everything
that allows us to evolve our inner world
the mind the intellect the soul he has
envisioned the end state of mankind as a
very enlightened state where the human
Spirit has reached the state of
self-actualization through a continuous
development of Reason knowledge and
examination of history for him history
plays a fundamental role in this process
and it is a task of philosophy to
comprehend and Define its place during
the unfolding of History hegel's
philosophy of History has a lot of
historical information it can be viewed
as a brief outline of parts of world
history from the early civilizations of
China India and Persia through ancient
Greece to Roman times and then tracing
the path of European history from
feudalism to the Reformation and onto
the Enlightenment and the French
Revolution he begins with what he calls
the Oriental world meaning mainly China
India and Persia a common pattern
identified in these three cultures is
that only one person the ruler is a free
individual the rest of the population is
lacking in Freedom because they must
follow mostly blindly the rule of the
head of their culture and the
subordination is not only a matter of
law but also a matter of how morality
operates within these cultures China is
organized on the idea of family the
emperor is the father and others see
themselves as children of the state
obedience to one's own parents is a
matter of Honor India is organized on
the concept of castes casts are social
classes and someone is born into them if
you adhere to the system your life is
defined by something exogenous and I
unchangeable Persia was a Theocratic
monarchy meaning that the emperor was
blessed by the religion of the time the
predominant religion of the time was
Zoroastrianism the problem with all
three cultures is that the concept of
individual conscience is absent
individuals cannot form their own
judgment about right or wrong and about
their self-worth these judgments are
usually orchestrated by external Powers
Hegel then contrasts the Persian culture
to the Greek one and sees the fight
between the Persians and the Greeks as a
fight between despotism and individual
Freedom so this was a pivotal point in
history and the fact that the Greeks won
plays a huge part in the development of
history and freedom when the Romans
dominated the world although the Roman
Empire was governed by an emperor the
idea of individual Freedom was still
prevalent in Rome there is a constant
tension between the absolute power of
the state and the idea of individuality
then came Christianity Christianity
allowed humans to see themselves
Spiritual Beings and this changed almost
everything the Christian religion has
this special element according to Hegel
because Jesus Christ was both a human
and the Son of God this is a great
lesson for human development because
allows humans to break through the
limits of the material world and realize
within themselves an infinite value and
divine Destiny since they are made in
the image of God the result is the
development of what Hegel calls
religious self-consciousness as he
writes the German Nations under the
influence of Christianity were the first
to attain the Consciousness that man as
man is free that is the freedom of a
spirit which constitutes its Essence
Christianity was the epicenter of the
intellectual life in the Middle Ages
however due to the darkness surrounding
that period Hegel perceived a medieval
Christianity as the facilitator of a
form of Consciousness that was unhappy
and cruel according to philosopher Peter
Singer it took a particular World
historical moment namely the French
Revolution for Spirit to become truly
self-conscious to escape abstract
freedom and realize concrete Freedom
through the laws as they apply to the
people even near the end of his life
regular meant jubilant about the French
Revolution describing it as a glorious
mental Dawn the spirit of the world
develops throughout history by realizing
the struggle with itself every stage in
world history acts as a stepping stone
for the next one for Hegel world history
is influenced by World historical
individuals so-called great men such as
Socrates Julius Caesar and Napoleon they
act as archetypes that influence the
tides of history and represent the Need
For Freedom he says these figures as
embodiments of the progress of humanity
to reach a certain point in history a
point where the notion of freedom is
expressed in different ways it is visual
to understand that Hegel doesn't merely
want to show that the amount of Freedom
has increased over the course of history
but that the concept of Freedom itself
has fundamentally changed and realized
its importance this process is a result
of a thesis colliding with an antithesis
and eventually forming a synthesis Hegel
didn't use this specific terms he used
the terms abstract negative concrete but
most Scholars use the terms thesis
antithesis synthesis because there are
less ambiguous thesis is the status quo
of the time that doesn't really serve
the need for freedom and antithesis is
formed and revolts against the thesis
the result is the synthesis of the two
that usually leads to more freedom
that's right and the goal for Hegel is
the greater development of Mind towards
Freedom we are moving always towards
consciousness of Freedom towards
realizing human freedom and
understanding freedom and that is a
process of increasing awareness of
freedom and of increasing knowledge of
ourselves
Freedom essentially means to act as we
please
but acting as we please has way too many
implications when the individual
operates within a social system freedom
is contingent on our needs and desires
but where do our desires and needs come
from some are organic and some are
constructed constructed needs are
byproducts of our systems in capitalism
we have an obsession with growth within
growth as a necessary constituent of our
systems without growth we head towards
stagnation and stagnation is not good
for our well-being so capitalism
artificially creates needs and desires
that accelerate growth we might not need
that new car or new shirt but we see
other people buying new things and we do
the same regardless of what capitalism
does to affect human behavior it is
difficult to distinguish the preferences
that contribute to genuine human welfare
from those that do not it is challenging
to put a label on the word Comfort
because it can be molded according to
the circumstances of a certain period
and people can manipulate the term to
make a profit off of it this remark
occurs in a section of the philosophy of
right that examines what Hegel calls the
system of needs Hegel constantly
identifies that our needs and desires
are shaped by our social systems and the
social systems in turn are stages in a
historical process what is the role of
the individual in this process is there
any amount of Free Will in that or are
we just being led by social and
historical forces hegel's answer to this
is straightforward we are free when we
reason we're not free when we act from
particular innate or socially
conditioned desires we are free when we
reason and then act the process of
reasoning is not an easy one thus
freedom is not so easy to acquire reason
develops through reasoning and dialogue
and Hegel puts a special emphasis on the
way Socrates was reasoning in Plato's
dialogues extrapolating from this and
trying to analyze this argument women
through the prism of world history I
feel that in the current day and age
where the closest we have ever been in
making reason a fundamental part of our
reality polyphony and the plurality of
channels through which many voices can
Collide and emerge is a healthy process
despite the tension that creates between
us even if some voices are unreasonable
and kakohanus we eventually reach a
Reason by the method of thesis
antithesis and synthesis
the idea of spirit in German Geist
it's Central to hegel's philosophy
it's Central to his conception of
reasoning to his conception of History
to the big topics in hegel's thinking
now Geist
is translated in German in English as
spirit
it's the part of the world the part of
that which is which isn't nature which
isn't matter or isn't exclusively matter
isn't exclusively physical
it's the part of the world that isn't
the tables and chairs
the animals and plants
simple brute matter Geist is exactly is
exactly everything that isn't nature the
notion of the spirit occupied hegel's
thought mainly in his Magnus Opus the
phenomenology of spirit just by editing
its title the book extracts the
potential reader as something quite
formidable let's start with an
explanation of the word phenomenology
the Oxford English Dictionary tells us
that phenomenology means the science of
phenomena as distinct from that of being
phenomena is a Greek word that means
appearances so the distinction between
phenomena and being is the distinction
between things as they appear to us and
as they really are there is a
mind-bending argument and we need to
understand that hego made this argument
because he was an idealist that is he
believes that reality is a mental
construct reality cannot exist
independently from the mind everything
is constructed in the mind so a
phenomenology of spirit will be a study
of the way in which mind Spirit appears
to us in the book Hegel analyzes
different forms of Consciousness and
showing how more limited forms of
Consciousness necessarily develop into
more adequate ones throughout time until
we reach absolute knowledge but what is
absolute knowledge that's one of the
greatest philosophical questions and one
I'm still not sure if I'm able to answer
after reading the book and multiple
analysis of the book I will attempt a
brief interpretation though reality is
created in our mind at first mind does
not realize this at first the Mind
perceives reality as something external
something independent he tries to
understand it but conceives it as
something elusive but when it comes face
to face with the fact that reality is
its own creation then it understands
that there is nothing Beyond itself the
Mind becomes one with reality and as
Hegel puts it in the concluding section
of the phenomenology absolute knowledge
is mind-knowing itself in shape of Mind
essentially he's talking about
self-awareness self-actualization and
spiritual enlightenment the more we
develop our cognitive capacity the more
enlightened we become and this is
manifested in the form of self-awareness
art philosophy science morality and
coexistence of cultures in any case this
was an attempt to briefly describe a
very dense topic obviously the book
consists of numerous Sasha loans that
need to be visited independently in
order to decode every level of hegelian
thought Hegel writes about reason
religion pleasure necessity culture and
much more despite the difficulty in
interpreting him he remains one of the
greatest philosophers in history and
influenced thinkers like Marx Nietzsche
Heidegger Foucault and Zizek I like to
call Hegel the philosopher of nothing
and everything it seems that when you
read him you understand nothing but if
you invest the time to investigate him
deep over you can come very close to
understanding almost everything about
The Human Condition I will leave you
with a very powerful passage from one of
his early writings promoted a lot by
slavoy Zizek the human being is this
Knight is empty nothing that contains
everything in its Simplicity an unending
wealth of many representations images of
which none belongs to him or which are
not present one cuts his side of this
Knight when one looks human beings in
the eye into a knight that becomes awful
laughs
[Music]